You didn't think we were just
going to be playing Asteroids
games forever, did you?
This is Pie Noon, it's a more
sophisticated example you can refer to
in order to see how a variety of how
more advanced techniques are used.
It's a simple multiplayer party game,
where you can throw
pies at your friends.
It's written in C++ and
supports up to four players using
a multiscreen mode with Android TV.
In this section, I'll introduce topics
in technologies that help you create
a great gaming experience,
as well as something to take advantage
of unique capabilities of Android.
We won't go into great depth
with each of these, but
you will get an idea of what
the different components have to offer.
And when you're ready,
you can explore further
on your own by following the links
in the instruction notes.
First up,
we have Google Play games services.
You can think of Google Play
services as a toolbox,
which is tightly
integrated with Android.
It helps you with common
tasks in game development.
These include storing and
synchronizing game data on the cloud,
as well as sending invitations and
auto-matching players.
Also included are tools to
help you build real time and
turn based multiplayer
gaming experiences.
It also helps you build achievements and
quests into your game,
which are great ways to hook players.
You can also collect analytics
data to help you understand how
players interact with your game.
All you have to do is create an account
on the Play Developer Console,
and this works a lot like the Cast
Developer Console we covered earlier.
All these features are free of charge,
aside from a small one-time
fee to verify your account.
After that, you can access all these
games features via Google API client,
just like when you use any other
feature with Google Play services.
And don't forget to add this scope games
when you create your API client object,
that's a common mistake that
developers do all the time.
Next up are nearby connections.
The nearby connections API let's you
discover other devices on the local
network and exchange messages
with them in real time.
This let's you do two great things.
First you can allow one player to setup
a multiplayer game on the local network
and then have other players join in.
Or much cooler in my opinion,
one player can setup the game on
a shared device like an Android TV.
Then other players can join
in using their mobile device
as a display controller combination.
Individual players see a customized
display on their mobile device
as well as a shared display
on their main screen.
This is a very unique and
extremely catchy capability, and
it makes your game super easy to use and
fun to interact with.
Inside the instructor notes, you'll find
a video demonstrating exactly how this
works, and doc you can follow
to build this into your game.
In Android 5.0 Lollipop or higher,
multiple networks are supported.
This means that there can be more than
one connecting network on an Android TV
device at one time.
For instance, both ethernet and Wi-Fi.
You can check for this case
using the connectivity manager.
And if so,
you can actually select the type of
network you'd like to use in your game.
Although there's usually not
a tremendous difference,
some developers prefer ethernet for
the slightly lower latency.
Next up we have WebP.
WebP is an open sourced image
format developed by Google.
It's more space efficient than JPEG or
PNG without a noticeable
loss in quality.
You can use this to
compress your textures and
reduce the size of your
final game package.
WebP supports transparency in loss
less compression as well as loss
compression if you need
even smaller file sizes.
As a default this is supported by
Android TV, so you don't need to
add any external libraries to encode and
decode WebP images.
There are also open source libraries for
other platforms.
And speaking of Pie Noon and C++, you
should be aware of the Android NDK, or
Native Development Toolkit.
This tool set allows you to implement
parts of your app using native code.
A really important note here,
the vast majority of apps will not
benefit from this approach, and
you should do this only if you have
a very good and very specific reason.
The best reason I can think
of is if you have a large,
pre-existing code base you'd like to
reuse, like in the case of High Noon.
Generally, the performance
tradeoffs of using C++,
if any,
are not worth the complexity cost.
Now on Android TV, NDK almost always
works without any problems at all.
However I'd strongly recommend you
test your code on a real device,
not on an emulator.